wo ich halte die da sogar du ehrloser
leute youtube wurde gerade erst von
einem neuen song von katja heimgesucht
und es geht direkt weiter mit den dingen
die man eigentlich auf dieser plattform
eventuell nicht erblicken möchte und
zwar leute habt ihr gesehen diese videos
müssen gestoppt werden und das müssen
sie wirklich denn wir reden heute über
eine ecke von youtube die sehr sehr
spezielles und nicht zu sagen
die idee für dieses video so entstand
leute wie waren letztens bei ikea wollte
irgendwas einkaufen und danach meint
dann so leute schaut euch mal das hier
an ihr sind wir über mich auf youtube
ich weiß was ich sagen soll aber es ist
so eine art compilation das geht heute
um diese art von videos ich kann zu
erkennen genau um das gehts sollte es
gibt diese eine ecke von youtube die
sowas hochlädt sony loops hot 100
prozent pervers und es gibt sicher von
sony das gibt es von adidas gibt es von
baby und eben auch von jana und die zeit
ist gekommen heute dass wir diese etwas
spezielle arten videos analysieren
kritisieren und uns komplett darüber
lustig machen
[Musik]
man darf keinen bh trägt mehr denn das
sind diese videos aber die motorrad
demokratie ja ich glaube die beatles
machen
ok alter kurses taxi das gerade ist also
schon nicht sexistisch und genau das ist
in diesen videos drin heute ist sind
einfach bilder von youtube
die irgendwie kurz nicht aufgepasst
haben in dem video das sich rausstellen
danach ja dann sieht man irgendwie so
gern ausschnitt wobei manchmal mit
absicht bestimmt arbeit daraus wird dann
ein ganzes video gemacht ganz plötzlich
nächsten weil sonst alles gestochen muss
ich leider sofort ansprechen weil die
textvorlage
[Musik]
ich muss dir mal vor du wärst du fährst
weil ich für youtube und dann gibt es
videos kann crafter hopf und du weißt
dass schauen sich leute diese videos an
und sind dabei irgendwie ökohof und du
willst dass ich manchmal du bist ja
keinen porno darsteller oder kein
nacktmodel also wo das normale ist bis
er von youtube macht in deinem zimmer
videos dann ist sowas mit der krankheit
aber das gibt's längst nicht nur von
sony wenn wir zum beispiel hilfen
janneck schnellhardt trimby hus das ist
auch so ein ganz schlimmer kanal kind
alter 650.000 aufrufe da unten auf seine
jungs hot moments allein dieser titel
alter ich würde dich mal vorlesen soll
die loops haut ist moments fsk18 vor
allem auf youtube macht sie in
achstetten und füße
ich muss ich muss wirklich los ok
schauen was es kurz machen leute
es ist halt schon so richtig gesagt ist
einfach so dass das bild das ist grünen
schweiz komme ich sitze in den video
daneben und der zoom ist nicht aus
meinem video
wir haben im bild genommen aus meinem
video und haben dann noch mal extra auf
jahres beine gezoomt belassen es ist so
wir lassen uns von ihm du bist ja ihre
freunde recht nicht und das ist so
fucking belastend leute vor allen dingen
da habe ich auch gedacht ich sehe mich
ja auch selbst in so eine art komplott
compilation mit mir auch wieder sofort
alter das halt dort wird ja auch so
gesagt das wird dir so gern erklären
halten würde
ich kann es wirklich nicht oft genug
sagen halte es ist so fucking wir
schauen dass man so was auf youtube
hochlädt
ich meine bei schlimm genug wenn man so
was auf irgend einer internetseite für
pornos oder sowas hochwertig man sich
eine kleine aber auf youtube selbst eine
sache reden ja diesen wieder so
übertrieben auf was und zwar schon
wieder im text die am kran kräfte
einfach mit k geschrieben
[Musik]
geh mal beschreibung das heiß erwartete
videos via excel mit allen hot moments
der letzten zeit dieser clip und hat
auch schon die iris youtube können als
instrument profis und dient keinerlei
zur bloßstellung der betreffende person
sondern lediglich zu unterhalten
braucht er das sind die halt jetzt
rechts dürfte sich von seite eine fahrt
bis jetzt war es schon wirklich hart und
ist es peking wird seine eigene freundin
oder die freundin des eigenen bruders in
solchen videos zu sehen aber jetzt kommt
das allerhärteste bei diesen videos
genau das was ihr es hier gerade seht es
mit das schlimmste an diesen videos also
ich glaube das problem dabei ist dass es
den einen oder anderen jungen menschen
gibt vor allem junge männer die noch
nicht sagen dass ganz kurz es gibt
menschen die schwer zu tun braucht es
halt so gehen und deswegen ziehe sich
sowas auf youtube rein und kommentieren
dann es ist also so ehren los man kann
es eigentlich mal sagen leute es glaub
ich klar worum es dabei geht und das
steht unter so viel von diesen videos
dass leute sich quasi zu diesen videos
und dann ihre zeit und ein reinfall mich
mein was geht weiter das ist wirklich
die härte leute stellt euch vor ihr seid
ja und es gibt nicht nur so ein video
über euch sondern ihr schaut in die
kommentare und dann schreiben leute ihre
fackeln zeit dar ein alter da würde ich
so loos müssen die sache ist solche
videos gibt es eigentlich von fast jeder
weiblichen youtube gibt mir namen
kelly hat kelly müsse es wieder auf
31.000 aufrufen wird das ein bisschen zu
hart was du auch jetzt ja leider sagt
liegt einfach an menschen oder und ich
will handy-akku alter die welche uhrzeit
zum trost sein
was soll der verwertungskette schon so
leuten die kein fuß haben sind hier für
seine top-note wollte jan aziz dazu
gestoßen und wir werfen noch mal einen
blick rein in mein liegt das video
sofort halter ich verstehe das halt
wirklich nicht mehr
also was ist daran hat wobei meine arme
ist zu sehen
nastätten und das ist es ja was was geht
durch den kopf wenn du das hier siehst
warte mal ich liebe meine arbeit ich
[Applaus]
verstehe einfach nicht also ich versteh
halt wirklich nicht was die leute da hat
finden damit es kein bild nachgestellt
ausländischen alt ist nicht klar wo ich
halte die da so war das eben so
erst mal ein bisschen anstand haben
willst dann grafites das ist
sowohl von wachs und ja da also schlecht
versucht hätten auf ja das ganz ehrlich
leute zu diesen videos kann man nur eine
sache sagen an 99,9 prozent dieses
wiedersehen
ich liebe euch seid die besten ihr seid
mein schatz soll man ja von 1 000 1
prozent dieser wie wir's machen